-[ Voice cracking ]
Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy, Golden Globe,
and Academy Award-nominated
actress.
You know her best from her roles
in "Unfaithful,"
"Under the Tuscan Sun"
and "Justice League."
She's currently starring in the
final season of "House of Cards"
which begins streaming in its
entirety on Netflix this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-Whatever Francis promised
or did is buried with him.
-No, I-I know.
We all need to let him go,
start from some kind of scratch.
Though, it must haunt you,
the fact that he died
next to you in bed?
-Please welcome to the show
Diane Lane, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Thanks so much.
This is so nice of you.
Oh, that's great.
This is your "I Voted" sticker?
-Yes, and I wanted to ask you
where I should put it.
-I would go right there. I would
go in the part that goes --
-My daughter said so. too.
-Yeah. There you go.
So you've already...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
-I'm psyched. I'm psyched.
-I feel like that's the
undiscovered country that
everybody has to realize,
is you got to vote early
because you avoid the lines,
it's such a better scene.
-Yes!
-And now get it out of the way.
You have nothing to worry about.
-And you have time to read
all the propositions
and measurements
and to have your say
in the future.
-Yes. All right. Great.
And, also, thank you
for my cough drops.
-They were handed to me.
I'm not a sponsor.
-They were handed to you.
Okay, gotcha.
So, this is really cool
that you are on the last season
of "House of Cards."
But obviously this is a show
that there was a lot of
uncertainty as to what was
going to happen moving forward
based on things that happened
outside the realm of the show.
-Yeah, we had a little more
zeitgeist than we --
Yeah.
-Than we...
-Yes.
-...anticipated.
Get your hand
caught in the machine.
That's what I call that,
when you suddenly
become part of the hashtags
and movements and headlines.
-Yes. Maybe. Yeah. Right at
the beginning of that, really.
But what was the --
When you showed up --
Obviously your first year
was this year.
What was the tone like
when you arrived?
-It was -- Well, it was
interesting because for me
I didn't want to be
an interloper.
I mean, I'm a fan of the show.
And to be allowed in,
I had to cram and catch up.
And it's sort of
like being a kid
on the first day of school
in a new school.
You just want
to seamlessly sneak in
and not draw too much attention
to yourself, you know?
But that was unavoidable,
because Robin and I were like
two cobras hissing at each other
whenever the camera's on.
So much fun.
-You also --
One of your co-stars
is Greg Kinnear.
You guys play
brother and sister.
-I like you in puberty.
This is adorable.
-What's that?
-Isn't it great?
-I mean, it's pretty sexy.
-It's working.
-Yeah. How do I keep it?
-So, Greg Kinnear --
-You know what?
I do not want these.
[ Laughter ]
So you guys are sort of
wealthy brother and sister...
-Yes.
-...who are trying
to control politics.
Very evocative of some people
who are in the news.
Was that a fun thing to play?
-Well, power is fun,
especially for girls.
-Yeah. Sure. Yeah.
-We know what to do with it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, it was --
That seems to me what will be
the most interesting dynamic
of this season.
-Yes, and I made a few jokes
about voting for Robin
for president.
I mean, Claire frightens me,
but Robin's great.
-Yeah, well, I want to ask this
because you're also in Matthew
Weiner's show, "The Romanoffs."
-All in one week. 18 months
of my life in one week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pretty amazing.
-You are primarily known
for film work,
but it does seem
in recent years,
a lot of film actors have
found their way to television.
Is it just the quality
of the work?
-Well, I think it's good
to walk through the open doors.
And there's
a lot more opportunity
in terms of the quality
of writing
and the diversity of experience
that women are allowed to have
on the small screen.
And, you know,
it's nice to be invited.
And such talented people.
My gosh.
I mean, if you're going to
start in television, go big.
I mean, I don't even
call it television.
Because it's --
Once Netflix introduced
binging through
"House of Cards,"
it was a game changer
for everybody.
And so now with Matt Weiner's
new show, "The Romanoffs,"
it's appointment
television again.
-Yeah.
-So we're going retro.
-Right, 'cause it is. Yeah.
-I mean, to go back to that,
it's fun.
-"The Romanoffs" episode you're
in takes place in New York.
You used to live here.
-Yeah, I grew up here.
Born and raised and bred.
-You grew up here,
born and raised.
-PS 59.
-PS 59. Wow.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so how has it changed?
Like, when you come back,
are you blown away
by how different it is?
-Oh, yeah.
My school is now a Whole Foods.
-Wow.
-My first kiss was in the
produce section, I guess.
Now, well -- Yeah, New York
has changed a lot.
There's a book I wanted
to get for you today
because I knew I was going to
want to mention this to you.
There's a book by E.B. White
called "This Is New York."
Do you have it?
-I don't. No.
-It's mandatory reading
for us New Yorkers
because New York betrays
its most devoted, loyal lovers
of the city because
it can't help but change.
It must change.
And we all feel --
This book was written
70 years ago, by the way,
and it's very timeless
and still true.
-It changes quickly.
-It must.
-Yeah, so, growing up here,
on Halloween, I have to ask --
Because I grew up
in the suburbs.
My parents would have to drive
me in a car from house to house.
-Ohh! You had trees.
-Yeah.
Like, trick-or-treating
was a drag.
-Lucky. That was the fantasy
of every city kid.
-Yeah.
It really is not that great.
-We would just go to the
richest girl that we could find
and be her friend for Halloween
and say, "Can we go to your
building for trick-or-treat?"
And we'd just go
to the top floor
and work our way
down the stairwell and...
-See, that's so much more fun
than what I had to do.
-...come out with two years'
worth of candy in one building.
-Yeah, I would take
like four hours,
and I would get,
like, a Kit-Kat.
-You earned it.
-I did. I earned it.
-What was your favorite costume?
-What was my favorite costume?
I actually remember
when I was really young,
I said that I wanted to dress
like a pile of trash.
[ Laughter ]
-That's different.
-And my dad
did this excellent --
made me an excellent costume,
and I still think to this day
it's the best costume I had.
Did you have a favorite?
-Well, I got to have my revenge
on my daughter
when it was her turn.
I got to make her
the costume I always wanted,
which was to be a mermaid.
-Oh, wow.
-Which is tricky, 'cause you
have to kind of waddle around.
-Yeah.
-You have to really be invested.
-How does it actually work?
You just put the two feet
out of the bottom?
-You make a little hole for your
feet in the tail, kind of.
-It feels like you wanted her
to get less candy.
That feels like the plan.
-I wanted to be able
to keep up with her.
-Just slow her down enough.
-Speedy McGee.